[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
qui sera essentiellement consacré à ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui aux états unis
on va essayer compliqué peut-être un peu
déroutant pour beaucoup d'entre vous on
parlera aussi peut-être des pros pas
raison entre cette situation et ce qui
se passe en france et puis naturellement
un peu du confinement et duco vide
auquel nous sommes tous ceux contraints
moi même je suis chez moi et pour parler
de tout ça alors en plateau il y a eu ni
porter bonjour vous êtes vous êtes de
franco américaine et vous êtes vivait
dans les yvelines depuis depuis très
longtemps mais et vous êtes surtout la
porte parole du parti démocrate
bon je réglais mensuellement dit que la
dendre est avec vous les journalistes et
les 78 puis à jeff hawkins
bonjour monsieur vous êtes diplomate de
formation vous avez été ambassadeur des
états unis en afrique et vous êtes
aujourd'hui chercheur associé à l'iris
enseignant à sciences po paris et je
prends aussi à sciences po saint germain
oui voilà
florence merkel choke et bonjour vous
êtes avocate au barreau de versailles
pourquoi patrice bonjour anne gaben
bésicles à duclair douzaine de
conférences à l'université d'oran
bonjour nous amène et pour jour stéphane
minson
bonjour ça va bien vous êtes professeur
à l'université des coûts versailles
saint quentin on va revenir d'abord sur
cette élection déroutante qui aux états
unis je vais commencer par vous jeff
hawkins
pourquoi ce décalage
vote républicain l'impression gains se
sont dus le le mardi au vote dans les
bureaux alors que le d alors que les
démocrates de voter par correspondance
pour qu'il y ait eu ce décalage bon la
première chose à se rappeler c'est que
il n'ya pas d'élections nationales aux
états unis il ya que des élections est à
par hectare et chaque état règle ces
élections de façon différente
il ya par exemple maintenant en 2009 à
sa chaise pendant cinq états où on ne
vaut que par correspondance
oui dans d'autres états il ya d'autres
règles et settat mais si les démocrates
ont voté ils ont voté en personne ils
étaient nombreux à voter en personne et
par anticipation mais si bon nombre de
démocrates ont voté par courrier par
correspondance et si la majorité des
républicains en par contre voter en
personne c'est à cause du duc omid donc
non seulement ça vous touche
personnellement ça nous touche
personnellement en france mais aux états
unis
il a une épidémie qui est vraiment
pratiquement contrôle en ce moment aux
états unis donc les démocrates qui
craignaient cette maladie essayez
d'éviter les foules et donc les bureaux
de vote et et donc ils lui disent ont
préféré voter par correspondance les
républicains pour par contre après des
mois où leur président leur a dit que
c'est pas bien grave
moi aussi j'ai attrapé d'acolytes c'est
pas sérieux vous pouvez voter ils ont
préféré voter en personne donc ça
explique un peu ce décalage entre les
républicains et les démocrates
alors je vais juste faire une petite
précision bien que j'avais invité à
l'origine un représentant du du parti
républicain et galbées et il m'a envoyé
un petit texto pour vous dire je
regrette mais je ne vais pas pouvoir
honorer l'invitation
c'est des consignes claires de meyer
archi au vu de l'évolution de la
situation
nous ne manquerons pas de venir partager
notre position lorsque celle ci aura
évolué mais nous sommes confiants
révélations à venir de l'équipe
juridique avec rudy giuliani est signé
powell
c'est à dire que du camp sont toujours
sur l'idée que peut-être des recours
juridiques pourraient faire changer le
sort de l'élection à me porter j'ai
l'impression que vous vous dites euse
l'élection ça y est c'est jouer c'est
définitif seven qui était lui bien
évidemment je ne sais pas pourquoi les
républicains sont encore dans le déni
alors c'est vrai qu'ils ont lancée
vingt-et-une procédures judiciaires
distingue dans différents états ils ont
échoué
vingt fois alors il y a un dossier où
ils ont gagné c'est à dire qu'ils ont
fait avancer les scrutateurs qui lit
regarde les gens qui dépouillent les
votes de sept mètres de distance
à trois mètres de distance toutes les
autres dossiers ont été déboutés parce
que les juges ont expliqué qu'il n'y
avait aucune preuve les soi disant
témoins n'avaient rien vu ils avaient
juste entendu parler à droite et à
gauche
donc bon ils ont perdu 20 fois qu'ils
arrêtent maintenant et que il
il arrête surtout de deux de soutenir ce
petit ego fragile de donald trump qui ne
peut pas avouer admettre qu'il a perdu
alors on en est je crois un 306 pour by
des 232 grands électeurs pour un dollar
c'est exactement la marge dans le sens
inverse qu'en 2016 donne un train pour
gagner trois sont si grands électeurs et
l'annoncé à tout le monde que c'était
leur raz-de-marée la plus massive de
l'histoire n'est pas vrai philippe
adrien j'ai pas absolument je pense
qu'il faut souligner qu' il n'y a pas de
doute
jobs n'a gagné ces élections il est
président élu à brest à être certifié
par les états etc
et puis entérinée par le congrès
américain
mais il est président élu et sida ne
chante pas donc
décidé de faire comme si le sort de la
république était toujours en doute
c'est certainement qu'il a ses raisons
et on a parlé de son ego fragile aussi
mais il y avoir d'autres aidants et
notamment la mobilisation du parti
républicain avant les élections
cruciales qui auront lieu au mois de
janvier dans l'état de géorgie un homme
ou dépendra le sort de la majorité
républicaine au sénat retient absolument
crucial quand on vote
il pourrait y avoir d'autres raisons
aussi mais tout ça pour pour que son
électorat lui restent mobilisés
maintenant et à l'avenir parce que trump
d'après c'est pour lui dans les journaux
il pense déjà à son avenir et son avenir
comme leader d'un mouvement
contestataire et éventuellement d'une
campagne 2009
j'ai entendu quelqu'un qui disait
l'autre jour où il ya trois et trois
mouvements aux états unis il ya les
démocrates et les républicains à il est
en piste
est ce que est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse est ce qu'elle est
restée des républicains s'est pas tout à
fait la même chose
non je suis pas d'accord avec cette
analyse parce qu'il n'y a plus de parti
républicain ça n'existe plus il qui a
les démocrates mais il ya un parti
républicain qui est qui a été pris qui a
été capturé par dans notre chambre et
donc les valeurs dans nos propres
représentent quelques quelques
quelques-unes des valeurs du parti
républicain mais son populisme son voire
son racisme sont censés appel aux
sentiments anti-immigrés de son aux
lecteurs ça fait pas forcément partie de
la tradition républicaine
donc le parti républicain c'est un rêve
construire et est si on laisse dans le
contrôle et le parti républicain dont
pour les quatre années à venir
donc pendant l'administration
en risque voire un électorat qui est
aussi polarisé aussi divisés à voir
jusqu'à la violence que qu'aujourd'hui
et c'est ni bon pour le parti
républicain ni bon pour la république
s'est imposée est ce que vous considérez
aujourd'hui que le parti des
républicains est dans la même situation
que le parti démocrate en 2016 c'est à
dire dans la reconstruction
non parce que le parti démocrate avait
des questions à se poser mais pourquoi
est ce que tu vas pas à gagner
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'avait pas prévu
cette victoire pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
été surpris par sa mais les valeurs du
parti républicain et la représentante du
parti peut en parler je veux dire les
valeurs du parti démocrate reste
elle-même
il ya un débat au sein du parti est
contre les progressistes et les
centristes
mais finalement c'est un parti qui reste
même avec un électorat c'est assez
diversifié assez large qui reste de
cohérent tandis que maintenant le parti
républicain ne représente plus les mêmes
valeurs qu auparavant et qui représente
encore une fois c'est ce studio
populisme de dan brown
alors pour bien comprendre cette
filiation je vais peut-être poser la
question de ce spécialiste de droit
constitutionnel que ce challenge du
clairet et c'était pas du mans sont
évidemment nous regardent sept états
unis un peu la dimension de la france
est ce qu'il faudrait pas regarder ces
états unis comme on regarderait
peut-être l'europe s'il y avait si on
devait élire un président en europe
parce que ça ne ressemblerait pas plus à
ça c'est à dire que les états outre
quand même énormément dans ce vote
plutôt que la nation unies justement ces
états unis il veut répondre sans même
nous les femmes il me regarde
précisément en l'union européenne c'est
quand même quelque chose de totalement
différent mais mais mais mais bon
avec l'idée qu'on en tout cas en france
on ne peut pas avoir un point de vue
valable par rapport à la situation des
états unis notamment par rapport à son
caractère fédéral de l'état c'est à dire
que l'équivalent de nos régions sont des
états aux états unis donc les états
fédérés ont une souveraineté ont une
liberté d'organisation qui est qui est
celle de de ce que nous la france nous
aurions dans dans une grande unité alors
l'union européenne est loin d'être un
état fédéral c'est juste une association
par traité mais il faut rappeler aussi
qu'en effet le système électoral
contrairement à ce que nous nous avons
en france tous le droit électoral est
une question nationale n'y a pas de
possibilité de le modifier les lois
électorales les modes de scrutin ou même
les modalités du vote dans une région ou
dans une ville ou dans une
intercommunalité
alors qu'aux états unis comme monsieur
raoult keynes l'a rappelé les règles de
vote tout le droit électoral est du
ressort de l'état fédéré donc c'est à
dire que d'un état à un autre
toutes les règles changent et finalement
c'est aussi ce poids du fédéralisme
qu'on ressent dans cette élection
indirecte qui est celle du président des
états unis c'est à dire que ce ne sont
pas les citoyens qui votent en faveur du
président des états unis comme nous nous
avons ce suffrage universel pour le
président de la république française et
c'est aussi cela qui coûte dans les
règles de décompte des voix dans les
règles de 2
de l'élection c'est ce qu'a rappelé la
cour suprême dans l'arrêt bush bissiau
score qui était justement cet arrêt sur
le recomptage des voix en rappelant
finalement ce n'est pas une élection au
suffrage universel direct les règles
sont nécessairement très différents donc
attention aux parallèles trop rapide
alors juste une question parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu il ya eu 7 cet épisode
d'autres corps et bush évidemment 2002
se souvient avec le recours des voix
dans l'état de floride signifie son
texte mais expliquant même dans
l'histoire américaine je pose la
question et me porter et stephen king
c'est la première fois quand même pour
voix un résultat arrivé aussi tard après
le vote du du 1er mars novembre moi je
veux bien répondre ce n'est pas la
première fois et il faut pas oublier
comme ça a déjà été dit que chaque état
compte ces voix de différentes façons
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a eu le résultat
de la floride par exemple qui m'ont
étant là où flotte le soir même de
l'élection parce qu'ils ont commencé à
dépouiller les bulletins 22 jours avant
le scrutin
pourquoi on a eu sita en pennsylvanie
parce que les législateurs républicains
ont décidé de ne pas permettre
dépouilleurs de commencer avant le jour
de l'élection
pendant les primaires en mois de mars
avril l'état de new york a mis quatre
semaines pour annoncer ses résultats
pourquoi je sais pas par man est content
très très lentement la californie n'a
toujours pas rendu toutes ces 40
millions de lecteurs ces bulletins
encore maintenant donc ce n'est pas du
tout la première fois la grosse
différence entre 2000 et maintenant
c'est que d'habitude ces bulletins
comptés qu tardivement par exemple les
bulletins des gens comme moi et de
l'ambassadeur aux kings
les bulletins des démocrates enfin des
américains à l'étranger
c'est que le nombre de nos bulletins non
jamais compter suffisamment pour faire
basculer le résultat d'une élection ce
n'est plus le cas parce que ce sont nos
votes qui ont basculé la géorgie et une
partie de l'arizona
on en est très fier mais cette fois ci
il fallait vraiment attendre de compter
tous les bulletins surtout le non massif
de bulletins par correspondance par les
américains habitant aux états unis
c'était fatma sont visés expliquer la
stratégie de drogue par le fait de
vouloir promouvoir chez nous le parti
républicain est d'avoir nouvel avenir
pour vous dis pas parce que nos ses
recours y'a pas aussi la volonté de
porter une ombre sur la très chic et
duke ellington
est ce que c'est pour suivre cette
histoire bien bien entendu puisque je
pense que votre analyse est tout à fait
juste puisque on sait que au fond
l'exécution frauduleuse ont été portées
par trump et ses conseillers avant
l'élection donc il y a eu des
accusations
aujourd'hui elles sont sans preuve mais
on peut dire qu'elle était a priori pour
en effet faire planer un doute je pense
que ça c'est une
c'est une technique assez éprouvée une
vieille technique mais qui avec les les
populistes que prend un relief tout à
fait particulier vous avez exactement la
même chose
la même chose entre attendre peut-être
l'élection présidentielle mais on voit
ce phénomène en contentieux électoral
pour les élections municipales par
exemple où les élections locales vous
avez un futur perdant quelqu'un qui sait
que de toute façon et du perdra qui
commence à laisser planer le doute
l'honnêteté des votes qui s'exprimeront
pour l'équipe l'équipe adverse donc ça
c'est une brusque une technique qui est
grossière et qui venant de churn
évidemment ne n'étonne pas alors
justement fait jeudi le rapprochement
entre ce qui se passe en france et ce
qui se passe aux etats unis
eh bien on va peut-être on peut regarder
un peu ce visage de l'ex où on va voir
les deux amériques et que c'est
peut-être aussi quelle façon ce qui nous
attend c'est le gagne tous les deux
amériques sacré alors il ya une chose
quand même
je parle il me porte à défaut le quine
ce qu'on attendait pas que les sondages
ne nous annoncer pas c'est quand même
qui à 71 millions d'américains qui ont
voté pour trump et que ça n'est pas rien
c'est quand même un énorme et vous
l'expliquer ce que vaut cette
mobilisation qui comme je ne pourrais
pas parler pour le parti démocrate
en tant qu'américain je dois dire que je
ne peux pas l'expliquer pour moi c'est
un mystère et et c'est justement parce
que en vidant deux amériques totalement
opposés et où jusqu'aux fêtes sont
contestés et donc 30 vit dans un monde
où la colline n'existe pas ou l'amérique
et great games et où et les légendes et
les démocrates les progressistes sont
des communistes sont des menace à la
république et son électorat est
extrêmement motivé par sa d'un autre
côté on a les démocrates les
indépendants qui sont plutôt consterné
par le
le tas de l'économie américaine qui
actuellement qui sont inquiets parce que
la copie de vraiment prend un essor
extrêmement et inquiétante en ce moment
et est donc trahi par ses dons de deux
communicants ils arrivent quand même à a
mobilisé beaucoup de monde mais
n'exagérons pas non plus il a toujours
été un président minoritaire
il a été élu par une minorité d des voix
en 2016 ils restent minoritaires à 100
ans en manteau de approbation n'a jamais
dépassé les 50% ce qui est du
pratiquement du jamais vu chez elle un
président donc même si chez sa base sa
voix porte très très loin en amérique en
général c'est pas le cas alors me donne
faim de défaut cds mais je vais quand
même interrogé d'abord dit ils étaient
minoritaires c'est vrai mais si on
regarde les élections de 2016 c'est vrai
que d'hillary clinton avait plus de
poids mais elle a surtout beaucoup plus
de voix en californie aucun mur de plus
en californie ce qui explique qu'elle
soit on tape on attendait en tant que
californien je dois te protesté parce qu
une voix téléphone yen est aussi valable
une fois lavés s'étaient situés
graphique peut situer mais on entend
quand même des gens qui disent oui
peut-être que non pas des personnalités
il a des moteurs est insupportable et b
si on met à parler économique il a
plutôt réussi négligeable et finalement
c'est
dix finalement souhaité un meilleur
président quelle est l obama alors je
vous demande pas de réponse c'est à ça
que j'ai peut-être été rosé est votre
regard vous moi j'ai fait j'ai un regard
inquiet presque intimiste et personnels
patrice parce que dans le lobe servent à
sion vous formulez l instant je ne crois
presque reconnaître ce que une partie de
ma famille qui depuis 50 ans a fait
souche en floride me raconte j'ai un an
notamment un oncle et une tante qui ce
nombre d la plupart du temps des
démocrates tout à fait convaincu qu'il
est de toute façon n'ont pas voté pour
donald trump cette fois-ci mec qui me
disait l'autre jouant en vision qu'au
fond il y avait une sorte de phobie
économique avant évidemment la crise de
cette paire une furie économique qui
faisaient eux mais bien des esprits jeu
de vous je vous l'assuré à des esprits
raisonnable mesure est très ouverte une
sont des racistes ni nationaliste et
c'est finalement réfléchissait se disait
que eh bien sans cette crise sanitaire
peut-être que les choses le destin du
trump est des états unis d'amérique
aurait peut-être aurait peut-être
changer n'aurait pas été celui qui se
décident maintenant voilà même si c'est
une anecdote mais enfin qui rejoindrait
le bouddhisme et me porter je pense que
vous contestez évidemment la thèse de
ceux qui disent qu il était sympathique
qu'obama mais je pense que le mythe de
l'économie trump est éteint une des
grandes réussites de sang
illustration c'est à dire qui crie haut
et fort depuis quatre ans qu'il a créé
la meilleure économie du monde et c'est
faux et archi faux il suffit de regarder
les chiffres
sous obama la bourse a aimanté beaucoup
beaucoup plus que ce tram qui a hérité
en fait de tout le boulot qu'avait fait
obama
mais c'est vrai que les gens y croient
encore mais au lieu de parler des 71
millions d'électeurs de trump je
voudrais qu'on parle de minutes des 78
millions d'électeurs de joe biden ce
scrutin n'a pas été proche il ya 7
millions d'électeurs décadence a fait 51
47 % alors que la plupart de nos
élections se jouent à moins d'un
pourcent baden a quand même gagné 2 4%
il a basculé cinq états que le trump a
gagné en 2016 dont 2 qui n'ont pas voté
des démocrates depuis des décennies
l'arizona et la géorgie donc byden à une
victoire décisive
ça c'était annoncé tardivement j'aurais
préféré que ça soit annoncé mardi 3 mai
on ne peut pas nier la puissance de
lectorat et je suis d'accord avec jeff
hawkins moi je suis un peu perplexe par
un vis-à-vis des gens qui ont regardé le
chaos des quatre dernières années
de toutes les problèmes des familles
séparées à la frontière mexicaine de
tout le désordre et le chaos que trump
introduit dans nos vies quotidiennes
tous les jours
plus le désastre du duc au vide et se
dire tiens je voudrais reprendre quatre
ans de ça ça me laisse absolument
perplexe aussi toujours avec plaisir
je ne sais pas si j'ai quart temps si
vous fait parce que c'est intéressant
aussi d'analyser peut-être l'élection
dans les cartes explique tristement ces
deux amériques vous propose de revenir
quelques minutes en 2016 pour revoir
donc la victoire de donald trump donc la
carte montre qu'il ya des victoires
décisives qui ont été remportée par le
candidat républicain notamment dans le
wisconsin le michigan et la pennsylvanie
3 et à 1 du midwest autour de l'art
j'en ai grands lacs au nord des états
unis eh bien ces étages les sites parce
que en 2020 cette année joe biden les a
récupérés donc le wisconsin le michigan
et la pennsylvanie ont été remportés par
joe biden et il faut savoir que ces
trois états à eux seuls ces 46 grands
électeurs à noter aussi donc vous l'avez
dit un ennemi le basculement de
l'arizona
onze grands électeurs supplémentaires en
faveur de joe biden une annonce faite
par les médias américains ce vendredi 13
novembre donc une victoire un peu
tardive
c'est un état où il ya onze mille voix
d'écart entre donald trump et joe biden
le camp républicain a gagné cet état
depuis les élections présidentielles
depuis 1996 autre victoire notoire 1 qui
reste à confirmer parce qu'il ya un
recours ayant un recomptage en cours
dans l'état de géorgie donkey et qui a
basculé un côté démocrate cet état du
sud aux mains des républicains depuis
1992 et il ya et il y a quinze mille
voix d'écart entre les deux candidats
alors quand on regarde la géorgie en
détail
vous voyez la carte de l'état de géorgie
on voit que c'est les zones urbaines qui
font gagner de joe biden les ville
d'atlanta d'augusta de savannah et
columbus avec une participation beaucoup
plus forte qu'en 2016 pour hillary
clinton hillary clinton était en tête 1
dans ses comptes et mais avec des voix
relativement aux vins beaucoup plus
basse que cette année c'est vraiment la
participation qui a fait la différence
on va prendre le même exemple avec
l'état de pennsylvanie est donc là on va
voir avec cette carte de pennsylvanie
que ce sont les villes de pittsburgh et
philadelphie qui ont fait la différence
un cyclo la banlieue un de ces villes
donc c'est les zones urbaines et la
toujours pareil c'est la participation
une participation
parfois c'est le double parfois ses cent
mille voix de plus que joe biden a
recueilli par rapport à hillary clinton
en 2016
alors justement ce que vous montrez vous
le montrer très bien et qu'il ya normes
différence entre les votes des villes et
les votes ou des campagnes ou des
périphéries et il ya eu une étude dans
le monde d'un chercheur qui s'appelle
jacques lévy qui dit au fond
il ya plus de vrais rita petites
divisions entre états démocrates et un
républicain
mais entre les villes et le reste du
territoire les villes vote ont très
largement démocrate
les spurs des petites villes et les
campagnes vont très largement
républicain jeff hawkins est ce que
qu'est ce que vous pensez d'abord c'est
de cette analyse est ce que ça vous
inquiète pas un peu ce qui est vraiment
deux amériques qui se seraient opposées
l'une à loudes claire 2 mai et je
partage cet avis mais mais faut se
méfier de ces cartes
la dernière carte que vous avez montré
c'est peut-être un peu plus réaliste que
les autres donc on voit très souvent les
cartes électorales de avec les états
avec des comptes et tout ça et souvent
ses traits rouges et on al'impression
oui c'est vraiment à une écrasante
majorité républicaine mais on en est pas
c'est pas les compter est bon dans notre
système sert pour les états qui votent
mais mais ce sont des gens des personnes
ainsi si on prend la plupart des
décomptes et dans ses cartes que vous
avez montré ce sont des cartes des
comtés ruraux donc assez peu peuplée
tandis que les villes y à beaucoup de
monde donc je suis en voit un tout petit
peu de bleu autour d'atlanta et de
savannah c'est pas pour autant que les
démocrates sont minoritaires dans le tas
loin de là et c'est la georgie c'était
très partagés entre les républicains les
démocrates malgré l'apparence de la
carte
donc là il faut faut quand même se
méfier un tout petit peu de la
cartographie électorale aux états unis
mais mais c'est vrai que effectivement
on a un parti démocrate qui étiez très
diverses qui à divers qui est qui qui a
beaucoup de gens de couleur à qui compte
les deux côtes donc le nord-est
américain de l'ouest américain les
californiens et autres qui est le
parrain partie des gens éduqués et
tandis que le parti républicain
maintenant
sous sa forme trempe est plutôt un parti
des gens blancs souvent des gens sont
beaucoup d'éducation et des gens qui
sont le plus touchés ironiquement par
les changements économiques
enfin les gens de couleur ça ne sent
aussi mais ils sont très touchés par ces
changements et il se sent ils se sentent
très vulnérable et il voit en donnant 30
pour des raisons qui m'échappent
d'ailleurs un protecteur quelqu'un qui
pourrait changer la donne économique et
je lisais ce matin un article ou un
journaliste parler de son expérience
dans un meeting des trois dans le
michigan et l'action pas parler de
toutes les usines de automobile qui
l'avait fait ouvrir et c est la dame à
côté du journaliste lui a demandé mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en parlait de ne
pas pas de tout ça de toutes ses usines
canto que tu chantes pas ouvert dans
l'eau dans le michigan et le journaliste
à nice parce qu'il y en a pas ça
n'existe pas d'ailleurs le secteur
automotive dans le michigan a perdu de
l'emploi depuis le depuis 2016 mais
c'est justement cette cette division
entre des gens de entre des américains
et que des divisions des divisions qui
sont encouragés par pour des raisons qui
lui sont propres
mais justement on n'a rien dit qui est
enseignant à l'université versailles
saint quentin qui s'appelle laury
canetons qui est un très bon historien
très bon connaisseur des états unis et
qui a publié un livre qui s'appelle le
rêve américain à l'épreuve de donald
trump et qui explique au fond que trump
a beaucoup surfé sur cette vague de la
nostalgie d'une certaine nostalgie de
l'amérique des années 50 mais florence
mercadé stéphane manceau est une salade
un désir adducteurs au fond est-ce qu'on
n'est pas assez proche d'une situation
francs
on voit bien qu'il ya deux amériques
mais je pense que si on regarde les
votes en france et hors de france et
d'air france peut-être qu'ils qui a peur
de perdre un certain nombre de davantage
du cancer
et puis ne font peut-être plus plus
modernistes il ya un politologue qui dit
au fond trump en france ça serait
l'alliance de la manif pour tous et dj
les jaunes
est ce que est ce que c'est pas un peu
vrai ça et ce qui est des comparaisons à
faire entre les etats-unis et la france
[Musique]
probablement sur les sports qu'on
retrouve un peu la même chose entre les
grandes villes des grandes métropoles
françaises et la ruralité et jeff
hawkins dans le monde de la ruralité les
gens comme de ce que disent les gens qui
sont à ceux qui sont abandonnés et aux
etats-unis trump a su parler à ces
personnes entendues ce qu'elles
voulaient entendre
il est assez malin sur sur ce sujet je
pense que vous pouvez avoir la même
chose peut-être avec d'autres personnes
c'est radical ou l'a pas encore mais il
faudrait qu'elle arrive en france
toutes ces thèses complotistes on
retrouve tout à l'heure documentaire
hold up mais toutes ces thèses qui
peuvent manipuler des personnes qui sont
effectivement vulnérables qui sont un
peu éloignés ville et qui ont inondé qui
ont des difficultés financières
trump a su lors de leur parler
d'ailleurs c'est une question comment se
fait-il que des démocrates dont le coeur
de l'électorat seraient des gens
justement qui sont un peu décrochés qui
ont des difficultés sociales
comment ce type que les démocrates
n'arrivent pas à parler cela ce monde à
secondes tout comme en france pourquoi
les élites entre guillemets n'arrive pas
à parler
ce monde rural également donc là il ya
une place pour apprendre en france sur
le même schéma
il ya peut-être un élément aussi qui est
important parce que là on voit que dans
ce scrutin aux états unis il ya une
grosse participation est ce que
finalement il ya ça aussi la question
est ce qu'on peut comparer les états
unis avec la france parce qu'en france
il ya quand même un manque de confiance
qui se fait ressentir par rapport au
politique est ce que aux états unis il
ya ce manque de confiance constaté
et est ce que en france il va y avoir
une participation aussi forte qu aux
etats unis cette année si elle est
plutôt plus fortes aux états unis en
pourcentage cela se passe pour la
dernière entre deux tirades mais non pas
pour la dernière en tout cas où on n'a
vraiment pas fait quelque chose de très
lumineux mais mais c'est vrai que je
crois qu'on on a plutôt pas ton par
rapport à la frontière de la
participation mais c'est vrai quelque
chose qui se manifeste comme une forme
de manque de confiance et de du coup de
berceau d'un complotisme de de
finalement de détresse en quelque sorte
et c'est vrai que donald trump se
réclament du du populisme et dis
toujours je ne suis pas un élu je ne
suis pas un homme politique ça fait
partie de tous et de tous ses meetings
et tous les mouvements qu'on a pu
rassembler sous l'étiquette du populisme
sont parfois d'extrême droite sont
parfois d'extrême gauche sont parfois
centriste ça prouve que finalement il
n'y a pas de courants politiques du
populisme mais qui a finalement une
aspiration sociale sociétale vers ce
type de discours et je pense qu'en
france nous n'échappons évidemment pas à
ce constat c'est à dire que là où une
forme de deux couches de la population
qui va être considérés comme plus
socialement aisés ou les traits va
croire aux informations journalistiques
ou se documenter avant de parler eh bien
on va avoir au contraire un terreau plus
complotistes avec une france qui elle
et plus la même de véhiculer des
informations qui vont être entendus
comme notamment contestataires et et il
faut dire aussi que c'est peut-être
l'erreur clé des élites justement quand
il ya eu un décrochage dans le discours
qui a créé ce manque de confiance qui
crée finalement la montée en puissance
des mots plus donc c'est ça le parallèle
entre la france et les etats unis c'est
cette montée de du complotisme et du
manque de confiance et j'ai questions a
ajouté m il ya aussi ces deux bâtons
excusez moi je voulais juste ajouter
quelque chose en tant qu'étranger mes
départs et deux premiers je trouve que
ce mécontentement en france que ce soit
les gilet jaune euros ils n'ont pas
trouvé leur leader pour l'instant les
gens là et ça c'est la grosse différence
entre de france et des états unis d'être
en piste ont trouvé l'autre amp tandis
que les français n'ont pas encore
l'honneur et c'est pas le pen c'est pas
mêlant chant je sais pas qui ça va être
mais gare à vous au moment où ce
mécontentement trouve sa voie deuxième
élément peut-être moins important mais
assez inquiétant c'est que vos
mécontents avoue ne sont pas armés 38
chez nous il sent fortement ram et ça
c'est une source de de l'inquiétude et
lorsque stéphane mention justement sur
ce ce que disait est ce qu'on peut pas
être inquiet justement qui est pas de
queue qu'un parti politique aucun leader
politique n'arrive pas à regrouper ces
mécontentements parce qu'au fond c'est
ça la démocratie c'est d'arriver à
évacuer les tensions grâce à
l'opposition politique grâce au discours
politique en la renvoie bien qu'en
france il n'y a pas de discours
politique qui rejoignent ces
mécontentements
bien sûr j'ai faut qu'ils disaient il
faut il faut que nous nous méfions la
raison
mais c'est vrai que le propre d'une
démocratie qui fonctionne c'est bien de
permettre la cristallisation de
mécontentement positionnement des
discours dans des structures politiques
dans des mouvements re mythique dans des
partis politiques même si la culture
française des partis politiques
elle n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'elle
peut être aux états unis d'amérique
parce on se méfie terriblement des
partis politiques
historiquement en france beaucoup plus
aux états unis et puis mais il a raison
aussi de souligner que les gilets jaunes
et cette expression était du sénateur
manuel et gilet jaune c'est un canard
sans tête
voyez bien là chaque fois que quelqu'un
a essayé de prendre un leadership chez
les jaunes y compris même dans le débat
dans la délibération et bien sa tête a
été coupée dans les heures qui ont suivi
dans ses sept ça c'est un mouvement qui
ne se cristallise dans aucun discours
rationnel dans aucun mouvement dans
aucun parti politique
en dépit des efforts des nationalistes
populistes d'extrême droite
d'un côté le rassemblement national
et puis des populistes d'extrême gauche
mélenchon qui les uns et les autres ont
essayé de se faire prendre en photo et
gilet jaune ont enfilé ont revêtu les
gilet jaune y compris d'ailleurs chez
certains membres des deux partis
politiques plus recommandables et on a
bien vu que ça ne prenez pas mêlant
forte forte heureusement alors c'est
vrai nous non tout tout tout ces gens ne
sont pas armés mais ont quand même dans
l'esprit des choses assez assez enfin
complètement loufoque à hiva sionnel et
je je je lisais dans la presse qu'à
quinze jours au fond je crois que c'est
un journaliste étasunien qui le qui le
disait avec my bones et enfin leur
pour de la raison et de la science avec
toutes ces histoires de postes vérité
post vérité aussi c'est une espèce de
féminisme à ce texte ordinaire 1 sur les
mensonges institutionnels comme s'il
pouvait y avoir une vérité invisible qui
ne sont en réalité que des sornettes
irrationnel que des mensonges
mais appeler sa fausse vérité c'était
dans le discours trump et c'était déjà
quelque chose de très fort donc il ya
une espèce de salade russe de malé strom
nauséabond qu'on retrouve en effet des
deux côtés des données dans chacune de
ces de c2c démocratie en france et les
etats-unis mais le tout est de savoir ce
que ce que chacun des systèmes
politiques de postes vérité c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de vérité donc ce qu'on peut
dire je souhaite juste ajouter un point
que je sais que j'ai peur que le propre
justement de ces mouvements comme les
jets les jaunes ou de ces contestations
on va dire plutôt complotistes autour du
de la gestion de la pandémie propre de
ces mouvements-là soin de ne pas
accepter de leaders comme le nôtre et
stéphane et soit justement de ne pas
accepter la gouvernance et peut-être que
la menace la plus grande qui pèse sur
mon nom n'est pas tant qu'un leader de
ces mécontentements soit trouvé mais que
ces mécontentements entendent être un
mode de gouvernement puisque moi j'ai le
sentiment qu'au fond l'idée que l'on
trouve pas de leader à ces mouvements
est tout à fait naturel puisque ces
mouvements sont simplement là pour
contester et j'ai peur qu'on entre dans
une france totalement déconstructive xto
où tout projet institutionnel soit
finalement vu à l'aune de la
satisfaction qu'il apportera aux
mécontentements et ça c'est à mon avis
le plus grand danger la démocratie
alors justement vous aborder l'avenir
ça va être le nouveau chapitre de cette
émission qu'est ce qui va se passer et
de maintenant
[Musique]
et me porter joe biden votre candidat a
beaucoup insisté sur la nécessité au
fond de réunir les états unis de
pacifier
après les quatre ans de la présidence
train de se réconcilier
mais est ce que quand on voit justement
les cartes quand on voit cette
différence entre ces deux amériques est
ce que cette cette idée de la
réconciliation n'est pas une utopie
qu'est ce que c'est pas une mission
impossible qu'il se fixe est-ce qu'on
peut réconcilier des américains il est
certain que la tâche que joe baden a
devant lui est énorme et c'est vrai que
il n'ya pas que réconcilier les deux
amériques qu'il aura à faire
la première chose qu'il a à faire c'est
de s'occuper évidemment de la pandémie
je suis heureuse de vous annoncer que
ses équipes sont déjà en train de
travailler
j'ai pris le soin d'imprimer les 34
pages de nos de gens qui travaillent
déjà sur la transition
ils vont s'occuper de l'économie du
climat de l'éducation de la santé de
l'énergie du logement de la justice
raciale et sociale des emplois tout ce
qui est 13h même de la nasa
donc les équipes sont déjà en train de
travailler et le fait que donald trump
continue à nier les résultats de
l'élection ne changera rien à ça même si
la tâche est plus compliqué alors après
pour réunir ces deux amériques comment
est ce possible de réunir une moitié de
la population qui ne regardent que fox
news et autres sources de soi disant
nous actu qu'on sait maintenant ce sont
des mensonges ce ne sont pas des faits
alternatifs comme a toujours dit les
clips trump ils ne regardent que ça ils
sont convaincus que tout ce que trame
plus leur dis est la vérité ils sont
convaincus que l'élection ait été
truquée ils sont convaincus que ben
laden ne sera pas un président légitime
donc en fait qu'un python fans en train
de faire exactement la même chose
avec my dance qui l'a fait avec obama
lui jeter l'opprobre en dix ans obama
n'a pas vraiment été né aux états unis a
un fils a tout fait pour délier jti misé
sa son mandat le problème c'est que
maintenant vous avez les sénateurs et
les représentants républicains qui sont
derrière lui et qui ne disent rien
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont tous les yeux
rivés sur la géorgie et ses deux sièges
au sénat qui reste qu'ils pourront faire
basculer les choses
mitch mcconnell pourquoi il ne dit rien
il n'appelle pas byden le président élu
parce qu'il a besoin des électeurs de
trump pour mobiliser pour ces deux
sièges en géorgie si les démocrates
remplacer deux sièges non pas seulement
le sénat sera à égalité parfaite 50 50
avec la personne qui tranche en cas
d'égalité et en madame la vice
présidente
elle pourra également sélectionné le
leader de la majorité c'est à dire que
mitch me collant sera écartée et c'est
pour ça que tout ce qu'ils font en ce
moment il faut le voir dans le contexte
de ce scrutin le 5 janvier en géorgie
jeff hawkins justement est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer rapidement baie de
manille à sable pourquoi comment ça
marche par exemple je veux signer des
accords de paris sur l'environnement etc
mais est ce qu'il lui faut pour ça lena
approuvent cette élite ou pas oui ce qui
te sont passées comment ça va se passer
ici toute l'habitation comment ça se
passe
notre système constitutionnel est assez
complexe finalement est basé beaucoup
autant sur les normes que sur sur le
texte de la constitution mais en général
un président pour vraiment construire un
vrai projet de société aura besoin de
législation tant que pour des veaux de
budget voté par le congrès des
changements de lois etc
mais comme dans l'autre choc lui-même a
montré à un président peut faire
beaucoup de choses par décret aussi
c'est qu'on appelle exact de morts aux
etats-unis et dans l'autre chambre sans
être
beaucoup servi depuis ses 4 ans et
surtout dans le domaine des affaires
étrangères les mains du président ne
sont pas totalement libre mais assez dur
il peut faire pas mal de choses
joba ne peut tout seul rentré dans
l'accord sur le climat
il ne faire pas mal de changements dans
notre approche sûr sûr sûr sûr l'europe
selon l'otan etc
il peut éventuellement je pense que même
sans le sénat il pourrait rejoindre si
les conditions le permettent la l'accord
avec l'iran à mais pour vraiment faire
son projet de société pour avoir une
présidence monumental une présidente
très très réussie
il lui faudra quand même le concours du
congrès est donc
n'oublions pas que en deux ans encore à
mi mandat on a d'autres élections
donc même si un jour j ça ne va pas dans
le sens que deux des démocrates
souhaitent ce qui est possible dans deux
ans d'aubagne peut dire j'ai un projet
de société
j'ai gagné les élections les
républicains ont fait opposition
constamment ça ne marche pas j'ai besoin
de mécénat tard pour gouverner et et
puis demander à l'électorat encore une
fois donné dans ce sens mais les
élections à mi mandat sont généralement
assez favorable au pouvoir exécutif ou
je me trompe peut-être les élections à
mi mandat
ils sont pas très favorables
si souvent souvent c'est le moment où
l'électorat exprime un peu son
mécontentement contre le président en
exercice
c'est vrai mais c'est pas c'est pas
certain et aussi comme un tiers des
sénateurs élus chaque chaque de tous les
deux ans à il y a des moments qui sont
beaucoup plus propice un parti à l'autre
pour des raisons logistiques c'est tout
simplement par exemple cette année était
censé être plus propice aux démocrates
tandis que 2018 était la plus propice
aux replis quand je pense que 2022
encore les démocrates 200 de moins de
sièges que les républicains donc ça
pourrait elle était bon donc vous êtes
dit mist est en tout cas vous expliquez
bien voilà mais contrairement à ce que
propose parfois au fond et je parle sous
contrôle de 2 2 stephano d'internet
le président jean hier plutôt moins de
pouvoir que le président français euro
mais y répondez par oui ou par non
stéphane ruines de toute évidence
hausser leur niveau on peut pas comparer
la situation française étasunienne de ce
point de vue là il n'y a pas vraiment de
situation de cohabitation aux états unis
d'amérique puisque il peut quand même y
avoir comme jeff aucune se précisait le
de larges compétences dans le président
que se saisir des leviers très important
mais il ya aussi une logique de de
débats et de recherche de consensus
je pensais à la présidence au début des
années 80 de ronald reagan qui qui a pu
faire avancer les choses fondamentales
avec un congrès élit mois assez
largement dominé par les démocrates
chose qu'on ne peut pas concevoir en
france en période de cohabitation jeux
sont vraiment on a parlé naturel est
déjà pas mal de complotisme c'est vrai
qu'il manque aux états unis et je
déconne on termine cette émission
parlons justement de ce qui se passe en
matière du complotisme et de pau vide
[Musique]
d'abord je voudrais votre sentiment
le professeur raoult qui est poursuivi
pour charlatanisme
on ne peut ne pas être d'accord avec
avec le professeur là où on peut ne pas
aimer et méthodes c'est un peu comme
trump des mais c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui est des diplômes qui a
fait des recherches charlatanisme ça
vous paraît pas un mot un peu inquiétant
et qui risquent justement de deux
d'aviver cette sorte de complotisme
pouvoir convoi gerber beaucoup en france
il de répondre à cette question
hasard des charlatanisme
oui c'était évidemment inquiétant alors
c'est un vocable qui veut dire beaucoup
de choses et pas grand chose au final
c'est simplement une manière pour
l'ordre des médecins de rétablir en
quelque sorte une sorte de discipline
qui soit commune est donc d'essayer de
de ne pas admettre qu'en serrant des
discours parce qu'il faut savoir quelles
du pourra ou s'était fait le chantre un
petit peu delà de la critique des
médecins en place dont c'est surtout
essayer de garder une cohésion dans
l'ordre qui est qui qui paraît important
dans le cadre de cette action
disciplinaire après sur le fond le
problème du complotisme c'est que
précisément il se nourrit de la critique
qui est fait contre mis en précisant que
justement plus on empêche de parler plus
ça signifie qu'il est légitime mais moi
un contrôle puis une prospère donc c'est
c'est tout l'effet insidieux de la fecq
news justement à la halla halla trump
heist c'est que plus on la contrôle puis
on passe pour des népotique et plus on
laisse prospérer plus finalement elle
n'acquiert plus le haut rang d'une
rumeur mais d'une véritable information
il ya un documentaire qui est qu'ils
aient fait beaucoup parler de lui que
j'ai regardé celui qui s'appelle hold up
qui justement défend la thèse ou ce
virus n'est pas dangereux ou faut il a
été cette maladie inventé par an et par
le pouvoir
pour nick autoritaire et légendes et
pauline sportive allait devenir un
terrasse et peut-être par les riches
pour supprimer un certain une certaine
population et comment vous expliquer
alors sans entrer dans les détails de ce
hold up on peut expliquer cette idée
balle ils deviennent de plus en plus de
succès il y au fond on ne nous dit pas
tout et même on nous dit rien des femmes
de bête mais c'est toujours la même
chose c'est tellement simpliste c'est
tellement super facile est super simple
de se dire rien a conclu aulas l'a cette
fois ci on trouve tout tout le temps la
même bouillie avec davos avec jacques
attali aussi qui revient tout le temps
dans les histoires on n'est pas moi tout
le temps du du bon vieux conclut judéo
maçonnique
on ne ressort de manière réchauffer
d'ailleurs de manière régulière
c'est tellement plus simple de beaumée
et de prendre du prêt-à-penser futile
aussi aussi médiocre que ce qu'il est
que d'essayer à la fois de s'informer de
réfléchir et surtout que de deux d'avoir
la force
lorsque je crois qu'il faut une
véritable force sinon spirituel du moins
intellectuel d'avoir la force de pouvoir
se dire je ne sais pas pour l'instant je
ne sais pas et je suspends en jugement
le conte ne supporte plus de ne plus
savoir où de ne pas savoir et donc on
comprend au vol qu'on prend au passage
des thèses des théories qui sont aussi
fumeuse et abracadabrant fumeuses et
abracadabrantes les unes que les autres
alors par les travaux out how qu'il a
fait de la politique il faisait que de
la science il adressé aux médias et tous
ceux peu moins de gens que je sais de ce
truc là c'est que son hydroxyque l'euro
qui fait grossir leur fait prendre le
melon
moi je ne sais pas
ça péri six axis aguerris de l'aco vide
mais je constate les dégâts
l'intellectuel que cela peut faire ça
réclame donc c'est moi je n'ai pas
regardé je ne regarderai pas parce que
c'est trop long deux heures et demie
j'ai beaucoup mis la fac ou à ne pas
faire va faire ne rien faire je peux y
aller que dan n auriez mélodiste de ce
genre de truc mais c'est c'est toujours
la même histoire c'est à dire quand on
voit le important document fait n'est
pas si mal fait je disais quelques et
les analyses de sue j'entendais les pros
cours à la fois complètement dingue il
est désolant de quelqu'un comme monique
pinçon charlot qui finalement
aujourd'hui regrette sa participation à
ce que blood elle voit le produit final
c'est moi c'est pas la première fois et
sans doute pas la dernière mais tout
tout ça elle est profondément c'est
désolant et 10 lots mais c'est une des
c'est une des façons d'agir du
complotisme cdh est d'abord de vous
noyer sous des arguments qui sont la
ligne les uns après les autres et sont
derrière des airs des boues qui sont
assez contradictoires puisque ce
documentaire de 10,1 bâches des
réussites a aucun danger et on vous
enferme est pour rien et 2
il est utilisé par l'élite mondiale pour
exterminer surprend le mot la population
alors il n'est pas dangereux mais enfin
bon sens afin d'exterminer ce qu'ils
sont contradictoires
pour éliminer les peaux et trois
milliards et demi de personnes
question pour terminer alors il nous
reste 46 goodwin cni porter justement on
parle du couple est-il du groupe antoine
aux états unis vous parliez des gens qui
sont armés est ce que vous avez peur
d'une violence qui pourraient se faire
jour dans l'est dans les semaines ou
dans les mois qui viennent
est-ce que j'ai peur d'un soulèvement
général non est-ce que j'ai peur
d'incidents ponctuelles qui pourrait
faire des dégâts importants à un niveau
local et qui pourrait nourrir justement
de complotisme dont vous parlez soit en
france ou en europe ou au soir aux etats
unis
absolument france cadets la faute
peut-être justement cette violence pour
le craignais aussi en france parce que
quand on disait que fo aucune partis
politiques n'arrivent à récupérer les
tensions et les oppositions ça peut
laisser la parole
we dance est possible qu'au moment les
confiner non pas d'un n'a pas de
mouvement mais c'est possible aussi qui
est des personnes qui se révoltent aussi
contre cette histoire de confinement dix
ans c'est un peu spécial
quand vous voyez bien ce sens les
entreprises et nie ces faits que nous
fermer des entreprises
ras-le-bol des restaurateurs des
artisans des commerçants et que tout ça
de donner une pulsion impliqués we dance
etc mais extrêmement tendue dans les
entreprises aujourd'hui je le vois sur
la partie du droit du travail avec
problématique alors à la fois économique
où les gens aux fans qui a des
difficultés économiques et les
entreprises
pas tellement d'autre choix que
d'essayer de restructurer et quant aux
structures aujourd'hui il ya des
personnes qui se trouvent sur le sur le
trottoir et c'est vraiment compliqué
après il ya des papes problématique
aussi alors là ça peut être aussi un peu
de complotisme notamment gelé un exemple
dans une entreprise sur des
problématiques d'harcèlement moral
espèce de crise aux salariés qui essaye
de monter des dossiers d'harcèlement
moral contre des dirigeants
je ne sais pas si on peut faire le
parallèle autrement par rapport au
politique et qui essaye de monter des
dossiers qui sont plus des trous et pas
sur des débats du ddmt
6dans mais est ce que je voulais je tire
sur hold up
je veux dire qu'en fait la première
partie de ces iem supporter les erreurs
du gouvernement
début ce qu'ils disent théorie ce que
j'ai pu dire je ne sais tu voulais juste
posé une question vient de nous quitter
vous étiez ambassadeurs vous avez arrêté
d'être ambassadeur à l'élection est ce
que vous allez retenir dans la
diplomatie et michael baden j'aimerais
bien je ne suis qu'un petit retraité
maintenant donc peut-être pas mais de
toute façon le nouveau président a
certainement mon soutien et il y à une
bataille morale à fait réelle du travail
à faire avec nos partenaires français
européen et je suis pas je suis prêt à
poursuivre ce combat là dedans que je
rappelle vous êtes très chercheur
associé à l'iris nous enseigne à
sciences po et saint germain merci
infiniment des faux guides merci
infiniment à charlène vézina duclair
merci infiniment et d'y porter et
nicolas landry qui était le cadet choqué
voilà j'espère qu'on nous tend un peu
éclairé sur cette situation qui peut
nous paraître un peu compliqué de
français merci à tous et à très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de passe
[Musique]